[Music]
oh life moves fast one day you're
playing Kick the Can with kids named
flick and Schwartz
next thing you know you're a certified
adult
Ralph dear old man
he was the best
promise me we're gonna make this a
wonderful Christmas that would make your
father so happy I promise
what have I done and that was all up to
me
I suggest you start drinking and don't
stop till New Year's
[Music]
after when you're done don't let him
kick you in the face
decorating it kind of feels like child
labor honey it's not labor if we don't
pay you yeah
cheers
that doesn't mean it was easy
wonderful
Wonderful Time
Sports I triple dog Daria oh I got no
[Applause]
that's brutal
slowly I could feel the Christmas Ember
beginning to Glow again
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
ER how about you
I started the whole damn thing
[Music]
decided that you could have one gift
early
what is it that is a direct hotline
Santa Claus himself
all right revelers welcome to your worst
Christmas shopping let's go
you have 300 million dollars in your
personal vault
for Christmas
[Music]
laughs
I don't want any trouble okay someone's
gonna scooch up that chimney
who is he because he's not your typical
Mall Santa
are you there
[Music]
time for some Seasons beatings
who the hell are you
but what if he really is the real no
such thing as Santa
he's Batman
they're all my naughty lick naughty
that's naughty
and what do you do to the naughty ones I
give my life a call
I believe in you Santa
[Music]
which one of you did that Prancer
so unprofessional
[Music]
on a bitter cold Christmas Eve one Dark
Soul is selected for Redemption by the
ghosts of Christmas past present and yet
to come the tradition that continues to
this very nice
Like A Christmas Carol yes yes if you
would just let me get this outfit so out
of all the people on the planet
murderers people who do gender reveal
parties I'm the guy you're gonna hunt
you know what forget it
I told you a guy is a level 20 Fame in
the Dickens come on I can take this guy
I'm your Ghost of Christmas present
I'm not watching your dramatic
re-encrapment hey I'm haunting you you
can't just run away from me when I'm
haunting you hello
I believe he can be a positive force for
mankind and he's got his hands all over
everything yeah I wish Mom are you
texting HR no
people don't shame we got a runner
that's just fun to watch
I'm here to change him to being a more
positive force for Humanity
[Laughter]
do you photoshop yourself into these
pictures of my executive VP I don't
think so
oh you want that what I want is for you
to shut up and let me do my job is there
a Ghost of Christmas grumpy because you
could do that job
[Music]
is where real change begins
Oh that's oh he's dead yeah he's
definitely no no he's fine he's good
well I'm not a burial anyway
middle child two brothers were actually
very close but they live in different
states only child childhood obsessions
Christmas magic
my name is Michael you're a great dancer
you're a terrible liar and that's kid
I've always imagined that my life was
like a typical romantic comedy you were
so confident and you just surfed off
your clothes like your stripper to
bachelorette party and I basically
shower with clothes on
don't just shut up now shall we go to
your place tonight here's my door before
we go in just open the door okay
what is this Michael oh you don't want
to oh my God they're in here too
I think you're very cool and I'm worried
that you're going to break my heart you
know that this is my friend Mike a
friend yes Mom just a friend what is
going on here who is this guy who's my
boyfriend your boyfriend I think it's a
great kid we may not look like it but we
are actually kind of hip oh my God we
were gonna go to Woodstock you know
well I am let's just take a moment to
appreciate this beauty
get what is going on are you all right
come down off the ledge Mike I'm seeing
a doctor tomorrow
I'm afraid the news isn't good
I was always afraid kit would break my
heart and eventually he did he broke it
open
foreign
look back this is less of a rom-com and
more of the love story you can't sleep
for four hours we promised bed all the
beds are occupied get my husband a bed
well that was Oscar worthy word for
Shirley McLean
I'm sorry I never told you how good your
ass looks in your khaki pants I was
afraid if you understood how beautiful
you are if you'd leave me thank you for
inviting us and it was Kit's idea I was
vehemently opposed to it
and like all love stories it never
actually ends
[Music]
I just saw on the calendar that right
now on Earth it's almost Christmas time
we don't have time for trivialities like
Christmas but Peter's so sad about
Gamora being gone
we go to Earth they're a really
wonderful Christmas gift
it would make him happy
[Music]
something special he will never forget
what about someone special
we are looking for the legendary Kevin
Bacon we're looking for the legendary
Kevin Bacon
the smaller monster I think maybe you
didn't hear
you
come with us as a Christmas present
[Music]
I'm through
[Music]
quite on set let's make some Christmas
magic mark action hi there welcome to
Chloe's cakes what can I get you fellas
I'm looking for the owner Miss Chloe
Donner that is me
oh I'm sorry cut
hi I'm Christopher the network wants me
to find out if Christmas movies are
worthwhile I'm gonna be on set for all
the production that's not necessary if I
had some ideas about the script do I
talk to you about those or
here's your antagonist what are you
talking about this whole thing is a
Christmas movie we need to follow the
formula big city pulley meets small town
girl they have conflict Christmas magic
is like snow in L.A there's no such
thing
do you want to join me for dinner I
would love to get to know you and this
movie stuff better hello
that is a stretch so why'd You Pick
Christmas movies we always spend
Christmas at my grandma's pearls she and
I would binge watch Christmas movies
together watching people fall in love at
Christmas time that's the feeling that I
always wanted to create with my movies
[Music]
oh
yeah can I give you a lift what have you
done I'm embracing the Christmas movie
we have a problem
I turned around
I didn't can't get off the line you
think she got off a lot no no no no
making movies is exciting
we're setting down the whole Christmas
movie division what
pretend you care and then pull the rug
out from under us I do care I want to be
the guy who helps create this warm
comforting safe place that the world
gets to live in at Christmas time
I wanna believe him but I don't know
anymore logic doesn't say Christmas love
Saves Christmas can I trade you in for a
talking dog not according to my contract
I got her she's fine she's absolutely
fine she is fine
[Music]
we are gonna have the most peaceful
Christmas this year
is this we need to call an emergency
Sisters Meeting what does the Christmas
family done now it's Dad
[Music]
has made several payments from a hotel
in Nevis in the Caribbean I've booked
tickets for the three of us we're going
to the Caribbean this afternoon what you
might want to start packing flight
leaves at four
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
get my brother Mr James Christmas
can't a man disappear without being
hunted down by his nosy daughters
oh I'm here to rescue
rescue I want you to go back to your
families aren't you just a little bit
I am staying here I think Dad is having
a massive emotional reaction well well
Jake aren't you full of surprised
another wonderful day the three of us
have to do everything we possibly can
and we have to convince him to come back
to England with us you three look like
you're up to no good no
what are these called a killer bee now
be careful they're dangerous and
addictive we're gonna do some more
killer bees
I hate you
family need to stick together
agreed
agreed
[Music]
a lot of change coming on James
dad wants to have fun he should have fun
who are you and what you've done with
Joanna
[Music]
I am on a Caribbean island with three of
my magnificent four daughters and I
couldn't be happier
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Merry Christmas thank you Amy are you
Santa it's from my hometown snowy Oak
what
[Music]
James Hunt why did you cancel the
Christmas party come on it's the most
magical Christmas celebration we could
get a tree or some Carol Singers no
money Amy
Lots changed why didn't anyone tell me
and risk you abandoning your career to
come here
foreign
[Music]
things might change but this will always
be home
I know I hurt you when I left the ranch
has lost a little of her magic
Christmas is a week away so that gives
us enough time for the choir to rehearse
and for us to light up the house and get
a tree yes
I haven't seen June bugged this happy in
a long time what happened between you
and Jennifer's mom
everything an enchanted experience
she always did have that effect on you
I can't hear the sleep I was ring
see you around Charlie
what do you think it looks like
Christmas
nice to see a family in the house again
I used to be so happy here she still
loves you James
don't tell me you haven't told her how
you feel it's complicated don't let the
one get away
[Music]
but only you can decide what to do
you were literally in a DNA of this
place
magic happens at Christmas and here you
are
[Music]
this year marks the 100th anniversary of
our town finding the Bells
how can those be Santa's Bells when
there's no such thing as Santa of course
there's really a Santa right Mr Martin
there will always be non-believers but
don't let them rob you of your Christmas
spirit
somebody stole the Bells
[Music]
yes ma'am are you going to cancel the
ringing of the Bell celebration
absolutely not the great town the
Pleasant Bay represents the joy and
spirit of Christmas sure I found this in
the garage Georgia bottoms wait a minute
you're the smartest person I know you
have to help us
memes motive opportunity this is what my
dad does at work it's how he decides
impossible suspects we have to find
another person who has all three of
these things they don't seriously think
you can solve this case do you why not
for starters you still sleep with a
stuffed animal
these are our suspects
maybe I should make this girl the new
shower
are you gonna need detective stuff
they found some proof I think we're done
with this if there's anything I can do
to help us your bottoms shouldn't we at
least try okay this is getting good
no one is going to rest until the bells
are back where they belong
[Music]
that I have a Christmas wish what is it
I want Mr bonus to be home with Kenny
for Christmas we have to find out where
it goes I don't think that's a great
idea
man up Kenny that's sexist
[Music]
it was the night before Christmas
perfect time for a story I think in the
near future it's illegal to take drugs
or drink except for one night the binge
as it's known where it's perfectly legal
to get drunk higher stoned
but this year they did what you wouldn't
believe they moved the binge to
Christmas Eve
what
is
why oh why did they have to put the
bench on Christmas
I'm not going to stand by because you
all want to do a bunch of Slam balls out
of Frosty's holes
Andrew We're Not Kids anymore this binge
is our chance to take our lives to the
next level you're gonna fix things with
your family I'm okay your mom's new
lover you're banging my mom
and I'm gonna propose to Sarah I'm going
over to her dad's house to ask him for
permission you don't want to turn on the
bubbles or nothing I'd like to be able
to see right through to the bottom too
many mysteries in those bubbles
hey come with me if you want a binge who
are you I'm angel I'm gonna show you
what it would be like if you were never
born this is terrifying
[Applause]
this party's dead Grandma you have a
heart condition you should have seen the
[ __ ] we were into back in the 60s
I lost their Grandma's ring and I'm high
off cocaine can you come get me
oh Chris did you break out of prison yes
it didn't matter because the binge is on
and everyone's excited about Christmas
again hey child what do you want under
the tree this Christmas
Avengers are coming man we're taking
over
[Music]
tonight all the rules are out the window
it is Christmas officially you spell my
name wrong why is that house smoking a
cigarette this is what I've been wanting
to say to you the entire night
damn I really was high and drunk when I
wrote These
[Music]
I'm back on the road it's just one long
rehearsal for opening I heart radio's
Christmas Eve special let's be real for
a sec I was homeless and now I'm making
my debut on national TV thanks to you
guys
you are the real deal Travers if it
doesn't happen
someone somewhere will give you the
chance you deserve so what can
you okay are you okay I just killed a
llama it's now pack up he's alive
welcome to Harmony Springs Oklahoma
I have to report to La by the 24th
what's so important in L.A I Heart Radio
how much is this gonna cost 2 600 bucks
show our new guests here some
hospitality
the phone I could borrow has anyone in
this town ever heard of a smartphone I
had no use for fasting around here
literally
I have to get a job while you fix the
bus when you're done I'll have two grand
and be on my way so what do you got in
town like this
a middle school you better start talking
I'd like you to meet our new music
teacher I think you are all mistaken the
performance for the Christmas guys in
two weeks you prepped these kids and
I'll cover the bus repairs
[Music]
calm I have to write my very own song
for iHeartRadio and I'm having a hard
time sometimes when things aren't
working you unplug for a bit I haven't
been to some plug since I was eight
I'll tell you what though I like the
unplugged get a whole lot better I do
too
place your hands over your heart this is
where you sing from not your head or
your lungs your heart
I just come up for air for the first
time in years
[Music]
you can't do that from here
[Music]
I always hope that my singing would
bring me to a home of my home
[Music]
sometimes real magic only occurs in the
Most Wonderful Time of the Year
[Music]
oh Nutcracker when did life become so
complicated my old playthings I wish I
could be a kid again and play with you
like I used to
Mama Mama did you hear that sounds like
squeaking
that's what I call a fight Nutcracker
Marie
foreign
[Music]
let us help you defeat them you want to
help me uh-huh
let's go we'll send those rats back to
the sewers they came from
there was an ancient magic loot I play
it and the Rats will turn back
let's go hunt down a flute
[Music]
and gather the family welcome
and Christmas Eve is for life
I won't let you down father what are we
supposed to do no matter what happens I
will never leave your side The
Nutcracker and The Magic Flute
kind sir what no need to stare yes I
know it's nice
every kid has that one gift they want
more than anything for Christmas
this is the story of mine
bookends and they have baseballs on them
I see that no not those Nintendo
a maze of rubber wiring and electronic
intelligence so Advanced it was deemed
not a video game but an 8-bit
Entertainment System
no Nintendo in my house I second that
looks like a no-go on Nintendo
I needed a Christmas miracle
year was 1987 or was it 88. Super Bowl
is okay it doesn't really matter
[Music]
it's the late 80s I was 11 years old did
you wear a helmet yeah we always wore
helmets in the 80s
[Music]
me and my friends would do anything just
to play one yeah you huddled Max is on a
play
what have you brought me
untraceable Cash Money
[Music]
one thing became clear I needed to get
my own this is bigger than Christmas
[Music]
this is our Vietnam I don't think that
means what you think it means I have no
idea what it means we're gonna get in so
much trouble
sometimes during Christmas just when you
think that all hope is lost something
magical happens
[Music]
sold out in 20 minutes suddenly one
woman punched a grandma right in the
throat same family too are you making
all this up no no no way
did you guys hear from the reselling
contest first prize is a brand new
Nintendo Entertainment System
I'm gonna kill you
hold on
[Music]
there are no rules
that Nintendo's mine
we want for a fiery ma this kid thinks
Sharif sucks video games
I've been doing all kinds of strange
things to children
what it was the 80s stuff got real
Red Dog this is Bluebird this is Rainbow
one what happened to Red Dog I changed
it poor let's change names now this is
Millennium Falcon super cool love it
rated PG
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
Tony and Simon robbed the petrol station
oh what fun we make tremendous criminals
I felt so good
we're all getting old no we were getting
old
[Music]
it's just one potato each just one for
everyone
[Music]
watch the Queen's speech well she's
clearly in some bunker set up you know
filled with tins of baked beans and dog
food
here's to the lives that we've shared
our beautiful friend
may we rest in peace
[Applause]
I just think we should be honest with
the kids we know the Russians want us
all dead they're sending poisonous gas
to kill us all in the morning it's not
the Russians it's the planet it's very
upset
it will kill anything and anyone that is
still alive
[Music]
we just want to make sure that you
understand that as your parents we are
not to blame
I can't
think it's not your fault either
[Music]
I've seen the road and there is no way
around living like that
[Music]
day 1200 of This Global Life restraint
increases
[Music]
sir remember the moving Spike we spotted
in the infection rate
sorry about that what have you got kid
well I cross correlated the data with
Worldwide IR codes and it changes things
quite significantly it's impossible for
a strain to spread that fast Crossing
Borders at the speed of light
crisscrossing the globe in 24 hours but
when did you get those Preposterous
figures uh Christmas Eve
looks like you've got your clearance to
engage
the world has moved on magic dust pieces
of coal it's time for something a little
more reliable do you have any idea what
you've done
step right to it
I didn't think any of this was right
it's real and now they won't stop until
it's all gone
foreign
[Music]
Jerry are back in an all-new holiday
movie
and With A Touch of Magic from old
smiley
you're just in time to say my newest
Jerry's nephew Tuffy creates his very
own snow friend oh I'm much more than
that kid I'm your new bestest pal but
when the weather outside is frightful oh
it's getting warmer guys better find a
way to cool down it's up to Tuffy and
Jerry to save their new friend it's not
like there's some magical place where a
snow Mouse like me could literally chill
out year round yeah there is Larry
Snowman's Land oh what are we waiting
for let's go but getting to Snowman's
Land
may be harder than they think
[Music]
get ready for magic are we ready
[Music]
music hey you know what we need tones
say goodbye
[Music]
bars
and a whole lot of cat and mouse
[Music]
get in the holiday spirit with a brand
new Tom and Jerry movie
Tom and Jerry Snowman's Land
[Music]